if you're confused about what you're
looking at good it's working
looking like a stick or a leaf is way
more common than you think
and it's a marvelous demonstration of
the power of natural selection
this leaf mantis not only looks the part
but behaves it those jerky motions make
it look like a leaf flapping in the wind
mattis's are of course ferocious
predators so they need to hide both from
their enemies and their prey then we
have the famous stick insects they to
make use of the I've had a few too many
technique whoa there when that doesn't
work
some species unfurl brightly colored
wings to startle their predators still
others excrete foul tasting chemicals so
what gives with all these insects
looking like leaves and sticks it's
natural selection baby no two organisms
are exactly alike some insects look more
like sticks than their siblings
predators pick off those with crummy
disguises but good costumes mean better
chances of survival small variations add
up over evolutionary time resulting in
some pretty astounding camouflage well
maybe it isn't exactly foolproof you
okay little buddy no all right we're
gonna say goodbye now